[Musique]
bonjour bas bienvenus ces bons nouveau
chez moi bon bah c'est des ruines
maudite
ça s'appelle le château de la sorcière
parce que apparemment avant il y avait
une sorcière qui y vit ici et c'est même
là qu'elle aurait tué le père noël c'est
intéressant ça et maintenant je suis un
vrai paysans et ça me va très bien
le château banque pas du tout c'est
juste que devront et un mode deviens un
peu différent par exemple quand je crie
un serveur rien ne se passe
ah oui non non ça servant lui c'est son
nom jean servant bien c'est bon genre
c'est bon c'est heureusement vraiment
chouette gars la vie c'est un équilibre
il ya des gens qui sont seigneur il ya
des gens qui font les chaussures
il ya des gens qui ramassent des mousses
de chevaux pour en faire des meubles
face et nous l'important c'est qu'on est
tous un rôle
j'ai peut-être plus de pouvoir mais j
plus de problèmes et j'ai pu de molaire
non plus ouais sont tombés au sud de
kaboul
[Musique]
bon j'ai discuté avec des seigneurs de
l'extérieur du royaume et on est célèbre
pour deux choses les mecs qui n'ont pas
d'armée et les mecs qui vendent des
potions génial non c'est ringard on peut
pas essayer de viser un truc un peu plus
au large dans le trône de fer
ouais ouais le trône de fer
mais pour ça il nous faut une armée
alors voilà à quoi je pense on démarre
doucement avec cent mille hommes au
colonisent les provinces alentour et on
s'est enfoncé pour la tante autant il
n'a jamais été question qu'on
envahissent les provinces ça c'est parce
qu'avant étaient des victimes de
pharmaciens maintenant on est des
dragons 1 mais moi colonisé c'est contre
mes principes mais on connaissent pas on
répand la culture pas ça que tu voyais
là le théâtre tout est truqué
ce que le tas s'est pas exactement vous
en pensez quoi pour une armée de son
binôme il faut beaucoup d'argent voilà
donc on va pas le faire ne souriez pas
des bêtises comme ça on va trouver
je crois qu'on a fait une connerie
alors j'avais pas c'est de bâtir pour
faire une chaise du coup je vais appeler
ça tabouret c'est nous 1 mais qu'est-ce
que vous foutiez j'ai eu le temps de
faire au moins un immeuble en vous
alors on travaillait au terrain quoi
faire pour manger enfin y'a que ça de
poivre ouais faut enlever les impôts la
plus ils vont pas tarder à passer les
écouler les impôts pour le seigneur
alors ça c'est pour la protection la la
location des terres mais c'est du vol
c'est pas toi qu'il avait instaurée à
l'origine ça ouais oui si le mec s'auto
scandalise en gros la wii ou imposture
soleil ou les gars parce que celui-là si
on le paie pas il nous coupe le sol et
un bond à leurs fans
habituellement c'est pas le seigneur qui
vient chercher les impôts mais là
j'avais envie de voir wall e loue la de
bord la technique poker sache que je
passe des moments absolument merveilleux
ici je suis venu donner des nouvelles du
château tiens ça c'était bannière si tu
veut les garder parce que nous nous a
fait faire d'autre des plus stylés et
l'emblème de ma famille tu peux pas
faire ça et je peux tout faire je suis
chef à et à devises là les mystères sont
de mini jeux l'effet de change est en
les dragon dragons j'ai passé un super
après midi non mais c'est pas possible
c'est dégueulasse les gars il faut
lutter contre ce gouvernement qui nous
opprime et qui nous pousse dans la
précarité la plus totale ouais ouais
donc qui est pour un soulèvement
populaire et un équilibrage du pouvoir
pour plus de bouffe je pense que j'ai
compris c'est qu'il marche à la gr et
quand même dit que je dis bouffe à 35
donc nous allons former un groupe anti
gouvernement je vais appeler ça la
résistance
ou tabous et 1 1
hurel j'ai besoin qu'on augmente notre
chiffre d'affaires on pourrait partir
bien sûr un nouveau parfum d'huile
essentielle est-ce que tu connais le
chèvrefeuille je veux m'acheter une
armée de 100 mille hommes
oh là que j'ai besoin de ta créativité
aurel en fait j'aimerais que tu inventes
un produit dcti gouttes
tu trouve ça super tu es heureux mais
dès que tu en as plus tu déprimes t'es
pas content tu tombes malade tu touches
ce n'est pas bien
un peu comme de la drogue quoi or elle
est en train de dire que je veux faire
de la drogue
tu me traites de voyous non non c'est
juste qu'en fait tu parles d'une
substance ou si les jambes à il tombe
malade donc du coup je sais pas si je la
refais voilà c'est très bien ça fait ça
j'ai déjà non l'afro guînes
cette interview
[Musique]